الفتره الاخيره شهدت تصاعدا في العمليات
القتاليه تهدد سلامه الملاحه في البحر
الاسود فهذا المسطح المائي يتوسط روسيا
واوكرانيا وتركيا
ورومانيا وبلغاريا ومولدوفا خط امداد من
هذه الدول نحو مختلفي مناطق العالم فمن
موانئه العديده تنطلق اهم المنتجات عدا
انه المنفذ البحري الوحيد لعدد منها اضافه
الى اهميته الاستراتيجيه بالوصول الى
المياه الدافئه النفط والحبوب وبضائع اخرى
تبحر من موانئها مختلفه على سواحل البحر
الاسود باتجاه مضيقي البوسفور والدردنيل
ثم بحر ايجه والمتوسط ومن هناك الى العالم
فاوكرانيا تعتمد على النقل البحري عبر
البحر الاسود في تصدير ما يقارب خمسه
وتسعين في المئه من منتجاتها الزراعيه
وبعد توقف اتفاق نقل الحبوب بدات بوادر
ازمه تهدد الامن الغذائي العالمي لملايين
الاشخاص حول العالم وقد يحدث الاسوا فعبر
الموانئ الروسيه على البحر الاسود ايضا
ينطلق 70% من صادرات الحبوب الروسيه نحو
العالم مثل القمح والذره فيما تتولى موانئ
بحر ازوف المتصل بالبحر الاسود
30% من الصادرات الروسيه
توقعت وزاره الزراعه الامريكيه ان تصدر
روسيا هذا الموسم نحو 47 مليون طن من
القمح
كما تصدر روسيا من ميناء تامان وعبر
ناقلات نحو سبعه ونصف في المئه من اجمالي
صادراتها من الغاز المسال ونحو اربعين
مليون طن من النفط سنويا عبر ميناء اخر
يضاف الى ذلك منتجات بقيه الدول المطله
على البحر الاسود المتجهه نحو العالم